computer how do I put the Joker in
Arkham Asylum quickest route no freeways
computer do you hear me hello
boost I have just taken away your
computer privileges gasp sir it's time
for you to stop this unhealthy behavior
you can't spend the rest of your life
alone dressed in black and staying up
all night good night Alfred sir
it's morning you need to take
responsibility for your life and it
starts by raising your son I'm sorry I
literally have no idea what you're
talking about
the young orphan you adopted at the
Ghana room I thought I was being
sarcastic
oh my gosh oh my gosh oh my gosh oh my
god oh my gosh oh my gosh whoa good time
right whoa wait
just Batman live in Bruce Wayne's
basement know Bruce Wayne lives in
Batman's attic Wow
don't touch that the Morea see what is
culturally insistent I Terry what do we
think of it glam bat this will
absolutely not wait what's that one
there I love it
my only trouble is these pants are just
a little tight I got an idea it's better
now I'm free now I'm moving come on
Batman let's get grooving I could only
look you in the ice right now are you
ready to follow Batman and maybe learn a
few life lessons along the way I sure AM
but first where's the seatbelt the first
lesson is life doesn't give you
seatbelts
anything I do
Oh Alfred I have incredible reflexes
Oh oh my goodness I am so sorry soon as
I get back to the Batcave
I will make sure that Alfred puts
seatbelts on there but for the time
being I'm just gonna put my arm right
here and we're just gonna gently ease
out of here
real gentle like I'm home what is the
password
nananana nananana Batman thank you I
love it
oh hey didn't see you there I was just
checking out some of the amazing selfies
you guys took down at San Diego
comic-con shout out to SDCC check out
these nerds oh yeah oh great bad suit
nerd oh yeah yeah nerd nerd nerd if you
miss me there and you still want a
selfie it must be honest who doesn't
want a selfie with Batman they check
this out
I think I do yeah I do
hello again uber nerd fans I heard you
blew up the Twittersphere about my sweet
new feature film the Lego Batman movie
you know it's kind of like the original
lego movie only vastly superior because
it revolves entirely around me so anyway
when you're as super as me you don't get
just one trailer you get two trailers in
one week check this out
hey mom hey Dad
I saved the city again today
I think you would have been really proud
they were Oh Alfred I am so sorry I have
incredible reflexes I should have known
better than to sneak up on him like that
were you looking at the old family
pictures again no I wasn't sir
I've seen you go through similar phases
in 2016 in 2012 and 2008 and 2005 in
1997 in 1995 and 1992 with 1989 and that
weird one in 1966 I have aged
phenomenally do you want to talk about
how you're feeling what no I don't want
to do that sir no sir no nope no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no gosh I hope we were recording that
we're not Alfred what did I say a br
always be recording
Batman first dry
oh hey I'm sorry just laying down some
dope tracks here and didn't see you
there but since you've already
interrupted my sick flow I might as well
tell you about my new feature film the
Lego Batman movie written directed sound
mix choreographed and painstakingly beat
boxed by me because I'm Batman in my
spare time I also cut together this
trailer filled with some but certainly
not all of my best hero moments and
zingers so enjoy it let man outs women
wait bat and I can forgot to drop the
mic
hey Peter I'm home I'm home I'm home I'm
home welcome home sir
initializing Batcave music so did
anything exciting happen today
I saved this to the again it was off the
chain
anyway I should probably have some grub
Alfred left your Lobster Thermidor in
the fridge oh that's my favorite
I can't wait not 20 minutes
I deserve this today today I deserve it
first dry
hey Peter I'm home welcome home sir
initializing package music so did
anything exciting happen today
I say the city again it was off the
chain
anyway I should probably have some grub
Alfred left your Lobster Thermidor in
the fridge oh that's my favorite
I can't wait about 20 minutes stupid
I deserve this today today I deserve it
this film is not yet rated